I'm just deep in thought
what is she staring at what do you think
she's contemplating this she's looking
at those tombstones and questioning what
it is in her life that brought her to
this point
and the like what those gears have to do
with anything above it why why is this
room is actually language is really
scary it is a very sinister place like
this room is upsetting like and there's
this there's this horrible thing that's
dangling a big dangly do blood was
coming out of it and I'm actually I'm
helping it along with more masks it's it
doesn't make any sense why I would help
them in this scenario yeah it's the last
episode if you remember these
consecutive it's probably well actually
judging by the fact that we didn't start
in a safe room you could probably
discern that we're recording right after
last episode but we deposited two masks
we deposited two masks you save Richard
I saved Richard it felt like I waited
too late in the day but it was way more
of an eventful episode than it felt like
a lot happened but I also died and had
to redo to that which was entertaining
for me so I enjoyed it but I can see why
you would be super him maybe because I
lost a lot of it just lost a lot of
progress how was my health night effort
though you got the wind crest back to
the day I'm fine alright so you have not
that many more armored doors so you're
coming along with disposing of that key
and great making progress there's stuff
here or did I already get all of it I
guess that's a maybe there was like I
was wrong okay so I am heal I have an
armored key that I haven't utilized yet
there is a zombie in there great they're
like four zombies in there well I don't
want to go in there you don't really
have to you will later on for that red
door but that's at that point you'll be
stocked up on weapons and whatnot
everything grenade launcher - damn you
got you made a lot of progress last
episode I do have a grenade launcher but
I don't want to utilize it because I
believe there's a giant snake coming and
I'd like to save grenade for snake okay
so I would recommend go to the West Wing
to try out some doors okay
on the first floor mm-hmm also haven't
saved in a while so maybe like go to the
West there's a typewriter in the West
Wing you don't have any gribbins on you
though so you'd need to go to the same
room it's not that much farther and I
don't I think the path is pretty safe I
mean this is right I tell you I beat
this game not last weekend the one
before it when we started the show no no
no because I need to refresh my memory
on there was the first time I played the
remaster I played remakes one of my
favorite games what's the UM what
differences are there there are just
subtle differences with certain items
but in general like the controls being
how they are as you're playing them is
new cuz it it's better right in your
opinion in my opinion I think the tank
controls function better in the fixed
cameras this game like there's a reason
they had those back in 2000 or sorry 96
or whatever was 98 for the original
because because the fixed cameras need
it works that it's from her perspective
instead of yours because then you don't
have to what you lost like God of War
devil maker I did when you move through
camera angles is there anything in this
hallway I don't remember there being
anything in there mm I think I killed it
and burned it I'm pretty sure it's been
a while I don't want to die because I've
made so much progress yeah I'm gonna
save him so take a go toward the camera
because where Kenneth was so there's a
blue door to my left is that where I'm
going actually was not the fastest route
through the same room but it works I
don't I just don't wanna die honestly
that's like all I care about
you'll be fine cuz we've just done so
much progress no no that's a crow this
crows are such [ __ ] faces I hate them
shut up your [ __ ] butts
the crow gallery now the crow gallery
was the painting area houses are doing
so now I'm upstairs so I just need to
remember this hallway no remember
anything anyone no my buddy go through I
go through the front door and then I
take a right and then there's stairs
shut up
I hate crows I hated crows before but
now I really hate him okay I remember
I'm taking a right and I'm yeah can I go
in that red door or is that not well
either way you need to go to that
hallway for the save room it's at the
bottom of the stairs probably should go
to the save room before I go into a room
like that no wait that's the one that's
locked isn't it you could try it just to
see if you again you don't to walk
through it you could try to unlock it
first helmet I got it of course of
course it all makes sense now
oh no there's a zombie in here no you
screwed him up last time
oh the regular one I don't know where he
went oh I can hear him that'd be funny
if he was it down here mm-hmm
so after a certain point zombies can be
in the save rooms no they cannot make
that up very good call no you're fine
hate you
this is my ps4 like menu at home right
now the 20th anniversary of it like you
can do the save room kind of theme
do I need my grenade launcher at this
point I would just advise conserving it
I will tell you a couple things you can
bring that expedite yeah save it and
then
you got it girlfriend where it's on the
desk I'm dumb here we go here we go
those early save spots are completely
useless if they don't have a trunk in
them you know that well I mean if you're
someone that carries around ink ribbons
then they're not but who carries around
ink ribbons who has that much space no
one no why no especially if you're
playing Chris you get six slots that's
not enough slots alright so what can I
take with me all right take the chemical
to use on plants I'm serious okay as
well as musical score kind of but not
mixed herbs yeah bring it okay we need
grass I'm trying to think if you're
almost done with E I need it no you have
to come back through here anyway just go
with this for now well uh don't worry
you'll find healthy well the musical
score is on the right path but you might
as well come back in here anyway after
this there's a zombie in here where am I
going now check a map out where do you
go do you want me to tell you oh I just
don't want to be in the room with the
zombies oh I'll just get out of here no
wait no just yeah check out that red
door up top you haven't been here in a
long time like episode 2 or somethin
even try this door in a long time but I
wonder where he's at he's upstairs
somewhere he's probably in the hallway
right above you right now cuz you didn't
see him at all other than that
so this door the right you you're fine
because that was the first one you got
fueling is there still fuel in there
yeah but you're full right now so here
we go
I just saved so I feel pretty good I'll
take that taser oh man this area sucks
it's huge
there's all sorts all unlocked though
except that red one if you can unlock it
that's a huge shortcut back to the first
hallway you ever were in pretty much we
could do that now yeah might as well
all right left lock pick that [ __ ]
shadow it's pretty bad shadow its
texture okay you can try this room right
now the world spell of promises all
right this is a oh you got fuel right
you bet your buns oh my freaking God oh
what's in there
got some magazine magazine I know I
heard you but there's something in the
my main priority is that swing you get
that battery pack in the hallway yes go
to the desk
there's a journal entry I want you to
read no there's a I'm not messing with
you I promise I just want you to read
this this is pretty iconic thing played
poker tonight with Scott and Elias or
Elias from security and Steve from
research Steve was the big winner but I
think he was cheating let's come back
one of the higher-ups assigned me to
take care of a new creature it
looks like a skinned gorilla feeding
instructions were to give it live
animals ah when I threw in a pig the
creature seemed to play with it tearing
off the pig's legs and pulling out the
guts before it actually started eating
grouse at around 5:00 a.m. Scott woke me
up scared the [ __ ] out of me too he was
wearing a protective suit he handed me
another one and told me to put it on he
said there'd been an accident in the
basement I just knew something like this
would happen those bastards in research
never sleep even on the holiday I've
been wearing the damn spacesuit since
yesterday my skin's getting grimy and
feels itchy the goddamned dogs have been
locked looking at me funny so I decided
not to feed them today
uh-uh that's mean went to the infirmary
because my back is all swollen and feels
itchy they put a big bandage on it and
told me I didn't need to wear the suit
anymore all I want to do is sleep found
another big blister on my foot look I
ended up dragging my foot all the way to
the dogs pen they were quiet all day
which is weird then I realized some of
them are except maybe this is their way
of getting back at me for not feeding
them for the last three days if anybody
finds out I'll have my head handed to me
rumors going around that a researcher
who tried to escape the estate last
night was shot my entire body feels hot
and itchy and I'm sweating all the time
now I scratched the swelling on my arm
and a piece of rotten flesh just dropped
off what the hell's happening to me oh
don't leprosy hives fever gone today but
it's she today hungry and eat doggy food
such a bad translation or is he like
getting dumber
hichy hichy scott came ugly face so
killed him tasty oh my god it she tasty
tasty room as I call it
come out of there he's in there
and that's Scott I can't think of Scott
oh no no no he dodged him yeah he might
I'll kill him now is he dead yeah do I
ever come out of this in this room again
no should I burn him anyway no I
wouldn't waste it sorry I used a bullet
I panicked
you have two battery packs now we're
just good to stun gun charges
all right what am i doing believing is
that him
is this his journal might have been no
no well yeah I think so is this his
porno poster on the wall swimwear mm-hmm
point out yeah look and then there's
another New Deal ad on the left
well there weren't clothes on nudes kind
of misleading you know what I mean
though I guess so
nudie booty Judy booby pictures Scott
was sending hot nudes hot news snapshots
for Scott oh don't hang on your wall
okay this way that's the short yeah and
I'm just opening this yeah so do you
know where that leads back to like the
first hallway you came in where that
first nominee was yeah and then the
basement stairs to the right okay all
right but there's more to observe in
here mm-hmm
so now that I've unlocked it I'll just
leave it there's a candlestick
can I light it with my lighter seems
like a good idea though
I see it oh my god he's on the window I
don't know what you're talking about
I see it where yes your shadow that's a
friend zombie what do I do
okay so he's gonna you think you're
freaking smart don't you I'm gonna run
through and get to the door on the right
okay
I guess he's not gonna come out me is it
just gonna work out red herring you
thought it was gonna jump at you I did I
thought I was smarter than the game Oh
what these looks like a puzzle
Oh
Oh oh that looks like it's gonna kill
you
oh my god what the hell is that it does
look dangerous what if I put the
insecticide in that water
earth would pass cluster
wait yeah I would say pay attention to
where those valves are going first
I'm afraid to go closer Green looks like
it's going towards it Oh where's red
though I don't know Red's going this way
mm-hmm Green goes no I know I'll go back
and look at red closer great turns right
there right turns toward the plan I see
yeah
what does great green also turns towards
the plant no it doesn't really and just
keeps going straight that way oh it
turns right here mm-hmm
that's mean that's kill that [ __ ] okay
so red made you look stupid
god damn it Mary no just kidding got in
you would have killed a shitload of
green herbs if you went green oh really
I made you away from that because the
first time I did I destroyed man there's
a lot
oh there are a lot that's so me and you
mess it's worse if you do it you go over
and if they still look alright but then
you're like it's wilted and won't do
anything I'll take that death mask cool
all right should I take some of these
plans yeah you're pretty I have this
save him don't deposit them I will
deposit these what happens if you just
try to run for it well the plant kill
you or will just hurt you it won't let
you pass I'm pretty good Joker mm-hmm oh
wait there's a zombie in there all right
so where's the city okay so I'm really
close mm-hmm
is there any doors I didn't go to yet
yeah yeah that one side one okay
you're full anyway so I would say go to
the safe room anyway shut shut your face
all right I'm going straight and take a
left and I go straight to the door
straight to the door I knew it
go go go but there's a thing in here I
should have gotten the other doors first
it wouldn't have mattered
why actually now you know what [ __ ] okay
yeah go back you'll be fine but go back
and go to that inside door this is just
for like wait well I don't have to
completely tell you what to take a right
take a quick left and go in that door
yeah got it
okay oh my gosh you should be
sufficiently far enough away from palms
sweaty nice wait Jesus wrong door that's
the edgy tasting room really yeah just
go across the hallway no name thing I
just want a door because it was fear
wait I don't even remember there being a
hallway I'm so confused yeah there are
you unlock the other side I missed the
hallway just go back through this story
right but I missed the hallway you were
just in the hallway I was yeah so go
back through and then go across to that
smaller room but it's a hallway across
the hallway in that smaller corridor
so imma taking this way right yeah
in here yeah it's just there's a dagger
on there I believe on that shelf worth
it cuz I'm just gonna use it these jerks
are gonna come after me
Oh blue and yellow okay so I mainly told
you coming here cuz to see that yeah
that's it yeah okay you could dodge just
obviously there's one guy there
so so I gotta take a right out of the
hallway and then a left through the door
you could do that unless I think I have
to dodge either way right so the guy to
your immediate the south part of the
hallway he's facing away from you if you
go right behind them they'll turn around
try to grab you but if you're fast and
can get by or you can just risk going
trying to bait the guy up top if you
come out and feel like weird about it go
back through to reset them and then I'm
back out I'm very reverent you could you
could bait him
do i bait him to the right and then go
to the left is that what you're saying
no because when he's turning the corner
he's already facing the left so I would
beat him left then go right you got a
dagger on the Shelf right outside the
door I believe so you could always just
there's a dagger if you're gonna use a
dagger ah you might as well kill him I
would say kill no cuz then there's other
ones in there now you know what you know
what yeah okay dodge the guy to the
south like to you're closer to you but I
can't see him go fast behind him nice
nice sweet oh I'm just for the purpose
of saving time the last armored door is
right to your left so just to get the
red of the key you go like this one
I wouldn't walk through it yet but
definitely use the key and you'll be set
it's a little bit of a trek back to the
safe room but it's still worth it yeah
slot
cuz you want me to save at least deposit
items okay um you're pretty good on
doors so I should take a left and go
back the way I came to the typewriter I
had a box right there yeah I mean
technically the faster way would be to
go through where you just came from
others to zombies so I would I would to
save defensive items that we just got a
long way
you mean the outdoors yeah out here
mm-hmm
and there's zoms
where hey hello Ken it's my old friend
and I see that you are dead again
creepin oh my mirror those are such
annoying crows I know they're so
annoying so you sound like crow you say
a ghost pepper
all right we're the hell a mine so I go
straight no I'm so confused so the
shortcuts to your right oh I took a
right while you're laughing on the
camera but her and I go up those stairs
no no no down the stairs you're on the
second floor yeah yeah yeah in here all
the stairs it's hard to tell if they go
down or up stairs
I'm tired stairs go both ways do they oh
there's a zombie here where is the
shadow just went through the floor oh is
that what that is I thought I thought he
was downstairs if third mask you don't
need to do it yet but I probably should
like I had it I feel like I should save
or am i saving - don't worry about too
frequently
don't worry about saving it should keep
one I will get rid of the mask for now
you have to go all the way back and get
it
alright so this is I might have to tell
you what to bring cuz these are I'm
trying to think
this is a pretty big one
I like okay actually so I
so I did okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna have to go back to that
hallway
you got the Dodge lobbies no yeah you'll
be fine all right so no grenade launcher
I would say bring it okay so bring I
want to give this away you brought the
musical score that's good also one more
just kind of ruining a part it's not
really brewing the puzzle okay this is
no no don't bring that this is one of
those things where you'll get there and
then you'll figure out the puzzle right
away and realize you don't have the
items all right bring the emblem that
wooden shield thing okay it's not a
matter of me helping you it's like not
even a puzzle is just like gonna get
there [ __ ] all right got it
I understand and remember the tiger I
had you examine yes yeah yellow and blue
or whatever yeah so there's an item you
should bring beside these but actually
[ __ ] don't bring that herb here's a blue
gemstone and I bet you I'll find another
one okay so hold on let me think this
through what's here what's your hell
that fine yet he's a green herb I could
always eat it right now wait I'm trying
to think they're gonna pick up that you
know what this is gonna sound mental
don't bring the fuel or the lighter
right now you don't need those
I always need them so I can bend the
buddy yeah you know what you're not
gonna need okay if you dodge them
properly you don't need extra animals so
get rid of the magazines 15 is more than
enough if you do get into trouble
you also have defensive by them so
okay so I'm thinking now yeah you should
be good now all right I'm gonna refill
while I'm a wait I don't have a refill
here yeah don't worry about that
don't worry about saving either yet
sorry so when you come through that door
there's gonna be a guy in front but he's
not a threat at all just go left down
the hallway again so she finds the same
things last time which way am I going
down your exit the same room down the
end of this hallway okay well that's not
where the same room is the same room is
here yeah you're in the same room so
then I gotta go up these stairs
no no you're going up to the top of that
okay why it's just like leave no I don't
want to actually know you're kind of
completely some downstairs are you I'm
not going here yeah yeah so yeah go to
the end of this one okay and then
remember he's gonna be in front you but
he's not an immediate threat just turn
to your left to your left not hers whoa
let me think this through okay so I'm
going and you let me take a right yeah
into that tiger room with oh in to the
hallway mm-hmm
got it got it got it got it got it holy
holy holy holy - take a right take a
right take a right take a right take a
right
oh my god nice hallway oh that's so
creepy they're just always there being
creepers
can you take the past away
Suite 6x or shows that's it that's what
I did all that for that's six shotgun
shells pretty valuable you they'll come
in handy trust me all right sweet I
wonder what happens when I put the other
one in his other eye so do you want me
to go back to the save room to drop off
these shells
no you can do something else first you
do the music score thing which is pretty
close by otherwise you'd have to
navigate this hallway in extra time
okay so you come out you're going down
again just make sure you go by him
pretty fast cuz he's gonna turn around
try to grab you but if you're just do
the same exact thing as last time
this um South ok I'm going that way yeah
it's a guy facing the wall right now
he'll away from you but you have to move
past him semi quickly so he doesn't grab
you he'll be fine
cuz using the shortcut again then you're
going through that door that we just
don't like we don't like it I like it
nice idiot yeah I don't feel good about
it
I saw anxiety yikes
alright so I could go down the stairs
and never been there before as far as
I'm aware yeah you went up to the top of
them look down into the basement and
freaked out he said nope but you did
just unlock this door I'm lucky oh right
let's go in there he tried to go through
the door yeah I saw it's not ideal but
whatever that's gonna be played at my
funeral and now say a wooden counter
made of oak it gives off a pleasant
aroma like a fine wine reminds me the
bar at the shining in the shining that
is kind of new well smaller room but I
would like that item please don't pick
those up right now I need it no that's
not how she said it
screaming the top of my lungs
that's an expensive-looking grand piano
that's unsettling there's nothing it was
a [ __ ] creepy ass hallway for nothing
why oh man just move it
this must be what smells so good
Beethoven who's that guy okay so I found
the pump this volume am I really good
piano player
my god okay
I did it I would have loved this jambe
jumped out of the piano oh it's a pretty
scene or it's just good at Pete you know
can I take this now no let me see your
inventory I'll just I'll take it on the
way yeah yeah you can I'll take it on
the way back no your you could take it
you're a music score is gone now she
remembered that pretty fast no she just
left down the piano nevermind no yes
should I replace it with the other one
there's no warning 11 days have passed
since arriving on this estate how did I
end up like this a guy in a lab coat
brought me um-um
that's me like an English Old English
spelling of Meagher no ma gray plate of
food and said me Audrey hmm sorry to put
you through all this but it's for
security reasons that's when it hit me
this all makes sense now there are only
two people that know the secret of this
mansion Spencer and myself if they kill
me sir Spencer will be the only person
that knows the secret but for the for
what purpose it doesn't matter now it's
too dangerous here my family I hope they
are all right I decided to escape
Jessica Lisa I pray you are safe how
could I be so careless where are they
keeping him there against his will
I lost my favorite lighter the one
Jessica gave me for my birthday now it's
going to be that much harder would
escape this dark place the date when my
fate was sealed
my aunt was hospitalized three days for
that Jessica and Lisa said they were
going to visit her I wish I could be
there with them
but wait even as I'm writing my memory
is coming back to me more vividly just
before I passed out I remember the man
the men in the lab coat said something
like most likely your family is already
I pray for their safety somehow I
managed to get out of that room but
getting out of this mansion won't be as
easy I have to get past all the booby
traps Tiger Eyes gold emblem I have to
try and remember for my own sake so that
was like their justification for why
this mansion doesn't make sense like the
architect was told to design it with
booby traps and secret passages because
like I don't know Spencer was just a
psycho that's like their their scapegoat
for why there's puzzles all over this
place
I feel like I should use this I don't
want to take it I have anxiety about
taking it
there's been no warnings in every other
game there's a warning for this scenario
where it says do not take will tell you
it's not gonna lead to any instant death
or anything this thing together
actually there was so remember remember
in the Statue room it said like let he
who presses the switch too early
wherever be ready for death same thing
with that key it said welcome the
eternal rest if you take this right
there were warnings if this one didn't
then maybe it's not gonna kill you okay
you're using wait for the gas you're so
dead oh man I'm so stupid
no kidding just put it in now where's
the when does the gas happen it doesn't
I'm kidding sweet now you have a gold
emblem what if I didn't bring it you
just put the regular gold one back oh
that's what I'm saying you would have
figured it out in the mid I have to go
all the way back to the save room I just
want to save any time jeez there you go
plus like like I said you were far too
confident I need to I hate this my
mansion looks like like Ireland from far
away it's far less creepy than
what you've seen but like I look at that
painting can you look at that painting
to them this one yeah no there anything
there
I'm trying I'm meeting a I really just
didn't remember all right I feel like I
should save okay I'd like to save I
don't feel good okay I have anxiety okay
but first I will tell you okay are there
zombies in here oh he tried to get to
that door I don't know you have defense
do you think I should just go through
that hallway there go the long way again
no all right
do you remember where you got the wooden
emblem the fake one that you just used
to replace it it was very early then a
really like literally one of the first
items you picked up no so you're close
by I'll tell you that okay actually yeah
okay you got it from though there is a
puzzle I'm not gonna tell you the puzzle
but you got it from above the fireplace
in the dining room down here like right
through that door so just go through
there before you save there's no danger
this store in the Red Room yeah okay
there is danger in there if the zombie
got through no no no that'll be in this
hallway if he got through you can just
kill him and then go to the dining room
okay I don't think he if he does bust
through then cross that bridge when we
come to it but you're good yeah you're
good right now
ooh nice nice so there's a typewriter in
here yeah so I should just use that no
right don't you think mmm Horry I should
do this just so you don't forget this
next time all right so there's something
I can do in here maybe yeah that's not
just talking about this already got the
original fake one yep interesting how
did she see that she was that's like the
dining room table from Batman
the first Michael Burton Batman Mike can
you pass the salt what can you pass the
salt what it's like jog over when the
Simpsons become rich parts on one end
and lisas on the other and Lisa's got
those little binocular things for the
rich people the really tiny ones with a
stick on the end she was mom Bart's
making faces at me it's big oh maybe
this is a heresy I was not a big
Simpsons person Oh
just makes me think less of you when the
two have run each other through the path
to your destiny will it be open
it looks like you can turn the gears
inside the clock try it yes uh-huh
fudge do I know which one that does aah
what do you mean run each other through
Samian like Ronnie tried to through is a
term for like dozen old-school medieval
turn like you ran someone through it
means you stabbed with a sword like the
sword went through their body at least
as far as I know it there I'm sure
they're medieval I did it a helmet
shield armor and sword decorations right
when the two have run each other through
the tap path to your destiny will open
the two have run each other through
sword into body kind of along the right
lines along the right path of thinking
thinking along the right lines is what I
was looking for mm-hmm and I found it
just much too later on it's late in the
day I pointed towards the sword into the
body maybe um I just feel like I'm
turning them haphazardly right
haphazardly right now - is that maybe
just the way this one works mm kind of
unlikely that you'll solve it like that
but cuz
let me ask you this is it where I leave
them or is it the motion of the ocean
where you leave them I will also tell
you there's a piece the puzzle you're
not really considering right now like at
all
scary I'm listening to you I'm thinking
no I'm thinking when I'm doing I know
there's a piece of the puzzle I'm not
even considering maybe there's a hint on
this wall with that guy getting run
through
okay short into chest long into head
that's a [ __ ] image yeah which would
you rather get stabbed in the face and
die quick or seven stomach and maybe
survive but also being excruciating pain
before you potentially die yeah I just
was it long to face long in the [ __ ]
long face that one is what happened okay
long in the face oh I did it yeah you
were dangerously close to solving an
accident last time nice
sweet I got a key
I got a key I'm gonna save the game
she examine it we need the chance all
right
all examinable forcing that episode a
little bit short I guess we could end it
short ish Oh shield shield shield shield
nice we did it we did it
we're the greatest if every time you
saved an R Kelly song came on I don't
know that many that one I was just
saying was the only one I know right
mixed to ignition
under that one no that's Nelly Oh even
you don't know who are Kelly is oh yeah
we were you gonna sing another Nelly
song yeah probably
no he's the one with the bandaid in
random spots every time our Nelly
yeah I can't I get it our Nelly
performing with an au pair Kelly all
right where's a shield door that's the
question [ __ ] all right so this is a
part where I I could just tell you cuz
there's literally one shield or it opens
one specific door yeah let's do this
okay this will be fun all right so to
get me killed
no I'm not gonna try get killed but
you're gonna see me there is your jerk
all right where is it you definitely
wanna go to an item room so I would say
go to I have to go to an item box yeah
all right
well I'll go through the dangerous
hallway mmm and you know Juke to know
you could avoid the dangerous hallway
all together go to it's okay the show
the shield doors in the East Wing so I
would go
upstairs in the main hall and then
pretty much avoid those hallways before
zombies in it now could you - if I need
it - yeah you can you could you call
them but eliminate any chance of any
risk
she said Euclid dog no go upstairs and
then cuz I can I know I'm not doubting
your abilities like I said well
conservative player in this game mm
south or north left or right door sorry
right door the one here in right now reg
there right now the one down there I
don't you don't even really need anymore
unless you want to go kill forest and
that's where you got the grenade
launcher is there any Psalms in here
no no gene stance
alright so Richard us through there
right and the one door you can open
shield doors right there at the top of
those shorts there's member where
Richard yes yeah isn't that where the
snake is so I would go to save him first
before we finish off the episode wait
before I go to this room well if you're
if you're correct and there's a snake
but I already uh
saved yeah but you have a pistol that's
about it you could do it ya know yeah
again I guess just the whole on let me
meet you hold on hold on hold on why are
you just gonna buy you so like brazen
right now hold on I let me check your
health quick or your inventory I'm fine
I got a name cribben you have an ink
ribbon how look at is that in 15 you
don't know okay
stop going hold on a second go get that
green herb you did just save okay [ __ ]
it I'll let you do every you want I'm
gonna let you go
are you just messing with me bite okay
I'm done talking I just I just saved you
spent so much effort trying to keep me
alive I'm done now
I'm white fanging you and just like
Megan to the wilderness
I got it turning I hate you I got this I
got this Jack London you got this man I
hope it takes 15 bullets to kill this
thing
smoky room I don't have a shotgun I know
but you can still get him like a devil
snare hanging from the ceiling right
there detective there's nothing in here
he's huge
no I can't kill him can I leave
oh my god how do I shoot it how do I
kill it yeah I would heal up I think
you're in oh I've been poisoned all
right no no okay so don't use the green
herb yet cause you might not get hit by
him
[ __ ] yeah use it because you could go
down to red without knowing with the
poison use it use the green herb yeah
yeah okay so your poison so it's gonna
keep but like I would not stare him down
does that count
what just happened
take do it yeah hooray
he's dead oh [ __ ] oh no that's nice
Richard he thought he'd get before you
wasted so much trouble on him but Oh
Richards super dead that's
did it get the mass back there get the
mask can I leave you can yes I would not
try to kill the snake right now
but get the shotgun I don't want you to
pass that up because that's pretty huge
mm-hmm I thought I already have a
shotgun you have an assault shotgun now
which holds ten and does more damage oh
okay
you did really well you are poison
though Oh fine which is fine you'll be
fine
but you got the assault shotgun which
hold ten shells and it's more damaging
Richard so here's the cool thing if you
would not save Richard earlier and
taking too long he would not have come
you wouldn't get this all shotgun you
would've just had to get the mask and
get out you got the last mask oh oh so I
was a huge deal so now you yeah you can
unlike that should I save ya like you're
dead the whole time I knew it you're
poison I just didn't want to tell you I
need serum no kidding you fine I wonder
how much time I have remember the path
to get there mm-hmm crap it's also save
for him so you're keep mine you're the
same opposite side yeah you're in the
same exact spot where Richard was when
you did the same exact thing close out
of this and then look at the normal map
it'll tell you where you are I don't
sound so hot alright so I'm going
straight yeah you know yeah okay
straight up to the left into the main
hall mm-hmm into the zombie zone again I
don't know if it pauses the timer when
you're in here so I would at least like
do as you can know what's your health at
oh no you're good you're green so poison
gradually brings it down so you have
more time if you had like ended on a red
and had no nothing and we're poisoned
that was something yeah what am i doing
it what you tried dodging him he's not
facing you no [ __ ] oh you got a whole
pillar you got that little corner you
can turn without yeah just turn through
there there you go nice
where how didn't even get in there I
don't know if they're just wandering
around so like certain certain events
will reset all right so I'm taking a
left going through the main hallway
going through the long hallway I got it
like certain events will reset some of
the layout there are some of the enemy
placements I think I think that's how it
works
Oh God Richard but it got a dog me amore
okay through this main door it's how I
got some NC on okay come this way you
dum-dum I mean I'm clutching my side
like kidney pendous itís looking so hot
alright this way great yeah and then are
there zoms in here very very well might
be alright so all I have to do is go
down the hall down the stairs stairs mhm
and then it's there take them off
okay just go just go that's so screwed
oh you're good you're right down there
oh you're yellow Oh hmm
[ __ ] just go into the safe room this is
so [ __ ] alright when you get into the
safe room grab oh [ __ ] get the serum
immediately don't yell at me oh my god
shut up I have sweaty palms
oh my god okay you're good
I was worried I might see you dying the
same I don't think I've seen that happen
before ever I said honestly don't even
know if they I'm assuming it keeps going
down should I use at this point just you
the first day it's Bray but I have these
snort these herbs I mean you know that
our first date spray are they same I
believe so
so you got past you on you got the
assault shotgun you got the last mask I
was good there's a good last ten minutes
aren't you glad we kept going mm-hmm
sweet okay I'm gonna save it was good
good
lots of progress right prog-rock were
you like did you know that Richard was
doing it for you or were you just
actually panicking and running around or
both what do you mean doing it for me I
shot the snake like twice he is he was
the one pumping it with a shotgun right
but I was distracting it yeah yeah I'm
not saying you didn't do anything
I did everything okay got the last mask
you can go down to that tomb again all
right let's do it right now on the next
episode the penultimate episode you're
just bookending these looked good evil
coming up next episode replay res evil
seven we did its entirety we did it
resident Knievel's over so we will play
we will put that max mask on and see
what happens we have two masks yeah
you're gonna put it on your face thank
you guys for watching we will see you
guys again on the next episode don't
forget to Like and subscribe
we like you those they help us keep me
this kind of stuff thank you guys so
much for watching
I threw me a weird noise I'm not
impressed they be